i'm obsessed with your dog hendricks
and we started another instagram page
you are full-on dog mom right now she's
completely changed my life in the best
way possible
i love that little creature so much i
call her my little fox
i've only had her five months but i
honestly cannot
think of my life without her now like
she's just a part of me
i love her so much and i named her after
my favorite guitar player
jimi hendrix and talking about joy you
recently landed your first
ever juno nomination for a country album
of the
year how are you feeling about it when
they said my name i was like
what what is it is this actually
happening especially
getting nominated for country album of
the year because this
heart theory is so important to me i put
so much blood sweat and tears into these
songs and have just felt them
connect to fans in ways that is really
hard to describe or
even feel in the middle of a pandemic
[Music]
now i have a surprise for you on behalf
of
bmg canada and stoney creek records we
want to present you with your first
gold single as a solo artist for the
single
want me back what are you serious
oh my gosh
go baby gold oh my god
this is amazing thank you guys for
believing
in me to be able to finish the year last
year with it going number one
was like so cool but this it's like
the proof is in the pudding the proof is
in the pudding and
this is the best tasting pudding ever
we have one more surprise for you uh we
have some special guests
to celebrate this moment oh my goodness
number one
isn't this amazing
what does it mean for you to see her
succeed oh so much
he's an awful lot done she works so
hard and we just get so so happy for her